welcome to microsoft research summit
2021 my name is dan chichen and i'm a
assistant professor from princeton
university
today i'm going to talk about prom
tuning which is a recent emerging
paradigm in natural language processing
the gpg3 model has brought us this new
paradigm shift in which we can use
prompts to acquire very large language
models to solve nlp tasks
that means that we can just you put some
natural longer task descriptions
together with a few examples as an input
query
and then we can ask a very large
language model like gpt3 to output the
answer
so in this example the task description
is translate english to french and the
examples are several pairs of the
english and french phrases and the
expected output is a french translation
of this english word cheese
so this is a very appealing paradigm
because it doesn't do any gradient
descent or model update and all you need
to do is to construct this prompt to
query the model
the gp3 model has a huge number of
parameters including 175 billion
parameters
and it's basically beyond the reach of
most researchers in academia and many
research labs
and the gpd3 paper also shows that this
prompting behavior only appears in very
large models
as you can see from this figure
if the model size is actually
reduced to 1.3 billion parameters it
doesn't work that well
however the commonly used nlp models
such as birth or robota models have only
0.3 billion parameters which is
basically 500 times smaller compared to
gpg3
so in the past year there arise a lot of
discussion and the research questions
about prompt tuning
and we want to understand whether we can
borrow this brilliant uh prompting idea
from t from gpd3 and use these prompts
to actually work with smaller language
models such as bird or robota
and there are many other key questions
including how should we even define
problems and how do you find group
prompts and what is the role of
demonstrations
so in this talk i'm going to talk about
two recent work my students and i did on
developing better prompting methods
and the first one is called l and bff
which is a better descript prompt
that works well in data efficient or
future learning setup
and the second work is called
opti-prompt which takes a different
pattern with a continuous of prompts
which can be viewed as a parameter
efficient alternative
so important though here is that both
methods actually work pretty well with
smaller language models such as birth or
reversal
so let's jump into the first work lmbf
which stands for the better future of
learning about better future fine-tuning
of language models
so this work was done by my peer student
kenya gao and a phd student from mit and
fish
so in this work we explore future
learning
and in most cases we actually only
consider using 32 training examples
and we adopt this idea called
prompt-based fine-tuning
so this is different from gpd3 so we use
the smaller language models but we still
fine-tune all the model parameters in
models like bert or roberta
but since we only use a very small
number of training samples fine tuning
could be also very cheap
and finally we also propose methods to
automatically search prompts and the
demonstrations and this removes the
needs of requiring domain domain
expertise and trial and error
so let me start with what is
prompt-based tuning
let's look at a simple task called
sentiment classification so give our
input text such as no reason to watch
here our goal is to predict whether this
text piece of text the sentiment is
positive or negative
so in standard fine-tuning or here
because called head-based fine-tuning
which simply insert a special token cell
is at the beginning of the sentence
and now we pass the whole input to the
transformer encoder and now we take the
header reputation for the cos token and
build a linear classifier to predict
whether the sentiment of this input is
positive or negative
in cross-based functioning we actually
take this input text and convert it into
a class statement by adding some natural
language description with a mask token
in the middle so in this example we
actually pre append or like a short
piece of text like uh etherness mask
after each input text
so we cut this part a part uh intervals
mask as a template
and then we pass the input to the
encoder and get a reputation from this
mask position and we ask the model to
predict whether the word grid or
terrible is a better fit in this mask
position
so here essentially we also have a label
mapping process that we actually map the
word uh grid to the label party and maps
a word terrible to the label negative
compared to standard fine-tuning
probe-based functioning has two big
advantages
so the first advantage is that it
doesn't introduce any additional new
parameters
so we just need to reuse the parameters
for the word predictions that people use
during the pre-training
uh in contrast standard functioning
actually needs to add at least 2048 new
parameters for binary classification
tasks in robotic large model this
actually makes a very big difference in
future learning
the second by formulating the downstream
task as a master language modeling
problem it can actually effectively
reduce the gap between the pre-training
and the fine-tuning
so in other experiments we find that
using only 32 examples
uh standard fine-tuning achieves 81.4
percent accuracy by using the
prompt-based fine-tuning resist template
can achieve 92.7 improvement uh accuracy
which is actually a very big improvement
so problems are great so because the
next question is how can we actually
choose problems
so we did some pilot experiments and
find that the choice of problems are
actually very important
so let's look at this statement
classification example again so here
again we use this template an input
sentence followed by universe mask and
if we use the
grid as a positive word and terrible as
a negative word it achieves 92.75
percent accuracy
so if we transcend to the good and bad
the accuracy drops a little bit
and then if we change the party word an
active word to like two random words
like cat and dog the accuracy further
drops
however if actually we swap the other
and we use a dog as a positive word and
the cat has a negative word the accuracy
actually drops a lot and this is
actually very surprising to us
finally if we actually use a terrible
propositive word and a great for the
negative word but this actually achieves
the worst performance and only achieves
so 83.2 accuracy
so let's look at another example natural
log inference so we want to predict the
relationship between the premise and
hypothesis is actually intelligent
contradiction or mutual so we started
with this label mapping yes no and maybe
and then we first start with this
template premise question mark mask
token uh common hypothesis and it
achieves 77.2 accuracy pretty good
however if we just find a remove um
cover the accuracy actually drops quite
a bit
and then if we put up
the premise of the hypothesis both
before the mask token the accuracy
actually drops significantly
and if we change the order or the
premise or hypothesis we use the
hypothesis question mark mask comma and
the premise the accuracy is even worse
and only achieves
62.9 acres percent accuracy
so this actually really means that the
choice of templates and also the label
works is actually very important
so the next key question is how can we
actually find google prompts
and the big change arise here is that
since we only have 32 training examples
or very small number of training
examples so how to find good problems
and evaluate whether a problem is good
is actually a very difficult problem
so in our paper we propose two
strategies automatically label search
and automatic templates search to try to
uh solve this problem
so i'm not going to elaborate this
automatically label search process
strategy so it's basically a root for
search
custom pruning process and then we
finally enumerate all the problem
combinations and find the best um
combination evaluated on a small number
of training examples
and in the automatic temporary search
we actually start with a label mapping
and we use our patreon t5 model as an
out of box solution to generate template
candidates
so since the t5 model takes our fill in
the bank pre-training objective so it
actually suits our needs very well
so we first concatenate all the training
examples with these corresponding label
words
and insert the t5 masking tokens x and
the y uh in this figure
and that means that we actually want the
model to actually output
so the basic field in these positions
for x and y
so let me do the autoregressive decoding
instead of conditioning on one single
example we actually condition the model
all the training examples and try to
maximize the overall log likelihood
and then we use the bing search to
generate top 100 high quality templates
and now we vary the issue of this
template generate template for example
in this example like um
the model is able to generate this is
mask or mass one and then we evaluate
each of these templates on a very small
um development set and finally pick the
best ones at the end
finally in this paper we also proposed
to incorporate examples as
demonstrations into our fine-tuning
process this is actually inspired by the
gpt3 model but gpt3 doesn't use fine
tuning
however different from the gpu one gpt3
did so gpd3 basically uh rendering
samples a couple of examples and add
them to the context so they call this
in-context learning
and what we did is we try to sample one
example for each class for example here
we sample one example from the positive
training examples and then we sample
another example from the negative
examples says
and then
we print all these like sample examples
with a template under the label word
that we chose and then we just
concatenate them with the input
and in our paper we also show that if we
have sample examples that are actually
semantically close to the input example
we can actually achieve even better
results
so we evaluate our um uh l and bff on 15
popular lp tasks including seven single
sentence tasks and the eighth sentence
paired task
in all these tasks we only use 16
passive number of classes examples so in
most cases we actually only consider 32
training examples
so in this figure we can see that
compared to
uh with using using prompt-based
functioning the menu props
is actually already greatly outperformed
the standard fine tuning by a largely
margin especially for the sentence
paired task
and then if we replace the manual
prompts
manual templates with our automatic
research templates in l and bff we can
see that the model can actually achieve
comparable even better results again
they are actually much easier to obtain
compared to the human design problems
and finally we are incorporating
demonstrations
further brings significant improvements
and this is our final model
and we also consider ensemble taking an
ensemble approach of many different
props
since our automatic uh prompt search
process can actually produce multiple
templates easily we can
compare the prompt results of our
general problems to ourselves the many
problems and we can see clearly uh clear
improvement improvements here
and then we can continue increasing the
longer number of plan templates so if
you consider using 20 templates this can
further improve the results thanks to
the automatic prompt search
okay let me quickly summarize this part
prompt-based functioning has a greater
advantage compared to a standard
fine-tuning in few shops scenarios
and how to find good prompts is actually
a very challenging problem
and we can also incorporate
demonstrations into fine-tuning
so in short a good prompts can be
actually worth hundreds of data points
so in this concurrent paper they even
try to quantify the impact of your
prompts in different language tasks i
encourage you i encourage you to check
out
so in the next few minutes i'm going to
talk about another work called optic
prompts so here the key idea is to
optimize continuous problems in the
embedding space
and this is a work done by my phd
student sushen chong and i'm friedman
so in this work the key idea is that we
can represent prompts as a sequence of
continuous vectors so actually the
biggest advantage of this is that they
are actually very easy to search and
optimize
and we in this approach we only tune the
prompts and the phrase all the other
model parameters so
hence they can be viewed as a like
parameter efficient solutions
we demonstrate a very good performance
in our factual prediction prediction
task and i will also discuss whether
this works for other tasks or not at the
end
so let me start with what is actually
just like a factual probing or factual
prediction task so the goal of the
factual probing task is to measure how
much how much world knowledge language
models encode
so for fact like direct x developer
microsoft we can write a prompt like
mask release the director x
and then we can ask the model to fill
into spam blank and ultrasound uh the
correct also which should be microsoft
so if we don't find the user right
correct prompt and if we use a different
prompt the result could be actually just
wrong and
the model outputs intel
and the prior work in this space has
attempted using better search problems
methods such as text mining or
paraphrasing or directly search over a
sequence of discrete tokens for this
task
so in this second auto prompt work you
can see that they can actually find a
sequence of words as a problem like the
atmosphere along dialogue clone totally
although this prompt is actually
descript but the words are actually very
hard to incorporate so we were wondering
why do prompts need to be a sequence of
tokens anyway
so this basic comes to the natural idea
of our objective prompt so in this
optimal prompt work we just propose this
idea that can we just represent a prompt
as a sequence of vectors
so here we simply define um prompt in
this format
so if we start with the x which
represents the subject
followed and then we followed the
subject x by 10 continuous vectors
since the bases are parameters that we
need to optimize
and this is then further followed by
this mask option
a mask token
so we just collect a bunch of the
triples that share this developer
relation like directx microsoft or aws
among amazon
and then the goal here is try to
maximize the predictions by optimizing
these 10 vectors
so this basic idea very simple and
straightforward
so in the paper we also proposed an
alternative solution so in which we
actually started from a manual prompt
like mask release the x
and then we just replace the two words
in the middle like a release in the
third by two vectors
and we use the word embeddings of these
two words to initialize them and then we
can just do a very similar optimization
process to actually optimize these two
vectors for this um this relation
prediction
so let's take a take a look at the
result of this optimal prompt on the
lama benchmark
so as you can see from this figure
so the green and the yellow bars here
represent some of the results from the
prior work using the search description
so they can quickly outperform the
value prompts uh from the llama
benchmark
and if we take a look at the last two of
parts of the bars red and purple so you
by using the optimizing the continuous
prongs of prompts we can actually
further include the accuracy from the
14-inch 42 percent accuracy to 48 ish
percent accuracy so the improvement is
actually substantial
so by using the manual problems as
initialization can also further improve
the performance and brings a 0.5 percent
improvement
so finally you may wonder why do we
actually care about the soft props i
think there are a couple of reasons
so first these problems can be actually
very easily optimized using gradient
descent and they can also work very well
empirically but there is a um i also
want to put a note here that this is
actually different from the future
learning of the l and bff work the
optimization process actually still
requires a lot of examples to optimize
and the second other reason that we care
about these soft problems is that
each task can be actually because we
don't you freeze um
all the other language models parameters
so each task can be actually simply
simply represented as a software prompt
so this is actually very exciting
because this can actually
provide us new ways to study the
relationships between the different
tasks or how we can actually do the
transfer between different tasks
finally there are actually also many
other recent work along in this space
along this line and they're trying to
use the soft prompts for different nlp
tasks including like the natural
regeneration tasks or natural or other
natural understanding tasks in super
glue or question answering tasks so i
encourage you to check out these papers
and the soft forms can work pretty well
in many different scenarios
okay so let me just wrap up here
so in this talk i discussed two um two
types of problem methods uh this
discrete from message l and bff and the
continuous problem method of keyprot
and there is a lot of really exciting
work going on in this space right now
and there are many possible future
directions for further exploration
including how we can learn from the task
descriptions and how we can actually use
the prompt to actually achieve the task
on transfer and generalization and how
we can actually use these accounts to
achieve better outward domain
generalization
so for all the work i just talked about
our code and models are available on
these links and thanks for listening